good afternoon everyone
dr hinshaw and i are here today to
provide our weekly update on kovid 19 in
alberta the data we're sharing today is
from tuesday may the 17th to monday may
the 23rd
the peak of ba2 cases has passed and the
current wave is receding that's good
news especially for the people working
in our health care system
our average pcr positivity rate is about
17.5 percent as compared to
approximately 20 percent last week
positivity rates have now been
decreasing for the past month which
indicates that there is less
transmission
and wastewater levels are trending down
across the province including in calgary
and in edmonton the two big cities are
higher but the other sites where we
monitor are mostly down to a fraction of
their recent peak levels
there's still lots of
covet virus around especially in
edmonton in calgary and we can't expect
it to go to zero it remains a real risk
especially to those who are unvaccinated
or under vaccinated
and there is still a lot of people in
hospital with covet whether it's the
reason they were emitted or not the
precautions that have to be taken mean
other beds are blocked and the system's
capacity is reduced but we are turning
the corner the number of coveted
positive patients in hospital is down
again and sharply in the past week
the total number of patients in icu has
been around 150 over the past few days
well within the pre-coveted base of 173
beds and of course we've recently
increased that base to 192
on our way to our target of 223.
the total number of non-icu patients in
hospital has also ticked down a bit in
recent days
the numbers and the smaller regional
sites have dropped faster than in
edmonton and in calgary
in line with the wastewater data which
shows that the ba2 wave is receding
faster in the smaller centers in our
province
total inpatients in the five regional
sites are now below numbers in may in
the five years before covent 2015 to
2019.
the numbers in edmonton and calgary are
still very high as i've noted before but
relief is coming as ba2 levels drop in
the big cities as well
it's been a long winter and a long two
years for our hospitals and ems and
they're still under a real strain so i
emphasize we're not just waiting for a
break from coven 19 we're adding
capacity across the system as fast as
ahs can create new positions and higher
into them
budget 2022 included a 64 million dollar
increase for ems to fund among other
things 20 new ambulances in edmonton in
calgary over two years
just this morning i was pleased to
announce that ahs is putting 19 of those
20 ambulances on the street this year
five in edmonton and four in calgary by
the end of june and five more in each
city
by the end of september to do it they've
created 100 new positions and extended
70 temporary ones that's on top of a net
increase of 230 frontline ems staff in
the past two years
the health workforce is under strain
after two years of coven 19 but we are
rebuilding that workforce in order to
add capacity across the system in ems
and surgery in continuing care and in
home care
we promised albertans a stronger health
care system with better access to care
and we take that promise seriously
ems response times are too long and
we'll keep working at it until we get
response times back down to within our
targets where they should be and where
they were until volume started to run up
last summer
in fact tomorrow we'll be hearing more
about steps to address the pressures in
the short term from our ems advisory
committee
we're taking action and we need
albertans to keep on supporting our
health care workers by reducing our risk
of hospitalization due to covid wherever
possible
that's why we're continuing to make
vaccines broadly available along with
treatments like paxologic
i'm also pleased to provide an update on
another product that was recently
approved by health canada called ebu
sheld
every sheld helps to prevent
helps to prevent covet 19 in
immunocompromised people for whom
vaccination does not provide adequate
protection to be clear heavy shelled is
not a treatment for coping 19 it's given
before exposure to help prevent
infection in someone who is just unable
to amount a full immune response to
vaccine
alberta's clinical experts have reviewed
the evidence for this product and have
provided a recommendation for its use in
albertans who may benefited from it the
most
starting tomorrow every shell will be
available to eligible albertans who have
solid organ or cell transplants or blood
cancer or are being treated with
specific immuno-compromising drugs
details regarding who is eligible to
receive have you shelled are available
at www.ahs
dot ca backslash covent
opt
as this is a very specific group access
to evasheld at this time will be
provided through specialist physicians
who treat these patients
please contact your specialist if you
believe every shell may be an option for
you
it is important to remember that new
research is happening all the time and
will continue to update albertans on
other advances to help protect them from
coven 19.
few measures in public health can
compare with the impact vaccines have
had over the years to reduce disease
disability and death from a variety of
infectious diseases this includes the
effectiveness of our cova 19 vaccine
program as i said many times the initial
cova 19 vaccine series as well as
are still
the most effective prevention tools that
we have they're the they're the best way
to prevent severe illness and death and
reduce the need for hospitalization so
please call today to make an appointment
or visit a location with vaccines
available on a walk-in basis in our
province
i'll close there and just add a note on
process
we'll continue to provide updated data
every week but we'll be moving these
in-person updates to every second week
so the next update will be the week of
june the sixth we'll confirm the exact
date as soon as possible based on dr
hinch's schedule and mine
thank you and i now invite dr henshaw to
give her update
thank you minister and good afternoon
everyone
between tuesday may 17 and monday may
23rd our pcr test positivity rate ranged
from 13.7 to 20.4 percent with an
average of 17.5 percent for the week
as minister copping mentioned earlier
the number of people in hospital with
covid19 has decreased from last week
currently there are 1040 people with
covid in hospital including 31 in the
icu
sadly between may 17 and may 23rd
55 deaths related to covid19 were
reported to alberta health an average of
about eight per day
it is always incredibly difficult to
lose someone no matter the cause my
condolences go out to all those who are
grieving the loss of loved ones
losses like these remind us that covet
is not yet behind us and it can continue
to pose a risk to anyone
it will continue to evolve
two emerging sub-variants of omicron
have been receiving attention
internationally ba-4 and ba-5
both of these have been identified in
several other countries around the world
available evidence suggests these
sub-variants are more transmissible than
earlier versions which means they can
spread more easily once they're in a
community
that said at this time neither of these
sub-variants appear to cause an
increased risk of severe illness
we identified our first case of ba-4
this past week through our ongoing
surveillance
the appearance of new variants and
sub-variants is not surprising this is
what viruses do
as we continue to live with covet we can
expect to see subvariance and variants
emerge
it is important for us to continue to
monitor the virus for new or
dramatically different behaviors and we
will continue to do so
the tools that have longed served us
well we'll continue to help reduce our
risk of becoming seriously ill from
covid19 and limit community transmission
ensuring you're vaccinated with all of
your eligible doses
can help protect you against severe
outcomes from the disease
it can also reduce the risk of
experiencing long covid after an
infection
as we go about our daily activities we
must remain mindful
we can each take simple steps to protect
our families ourselves and our
communities
everything we've learned to do since
covid came into our lives such as
masking in places like acute care and
continuing care settings and staying
home and away from others when sick
will help protect those who are most at
risk
and limit any possible spread
thank you and we're happy to take
questions
thanks dr hinshaw no one here in person
so we'll go to the phone we'll take the
first caller please
thank you the first question is from
kevin mimick ctv
dr hanshaw i'm hoping you can provide an
update on the acute juvenile hepatitis
cases in this province
sure we
now have three cases that meet the
probable world health organization
definition which is to say that other
common causes of hepatitis have been
ruled out
when
the update provided by the federal
government was released last week that
third case was added in the reports that
came to us one of those cases was
had been discharged from hospital and
two were still in hospital but at this
time there are no cases in alberta that
have required significant attention such
as a liver transplant
thanks dr hanchov kevin a follow-up
yeah i'm wondering if these are being
traced at all
locally in alberta i understand that
most of the information comes from the
federal government in terms of
classifying the three uh youth as uh
having a probable case of this but
what's being done locally to
determine emerging outbreaks of this
disease
the national reporting comes from us so
at the provincial level we at the
ministry work with our partners in
alberta health services and through them
with frontline physicians who would be
treating patients who have these
symptoms and so physicians who see a
patient who meets the the criteria who
have a
severe case of hepatitis where the more
common causes are not diagnosed would
report to their local public health
teams and local public health would
report to us at the ministry of health
we continually monitor those cases to
determine if there are linkages at this
time no linkages have been identified
locally and then we provide that
information to the public health agency
of canada through required national
reporting in order to facilitate
international reporting since this is a
global issue that's being monitored
right now
thanks dr henshaw we'll take one more
call so we'll go to the second one
please
thank you michelle belfontaine
cbc oh hi there thank you for checking
my question um this is a question for
minister copping
uh minister my colleague asked you today
earlier today about the insulin pump
town hall
last week and i just need to clarify
something that you told her
keep talking about how no one would be
left behind by the change
and when you she asked you about what
you meant by that instead we will make
sure the program that we deliver ensures
that the pumps are affordable and that
people have access to it unquote so
minister i'm wondering this sounds like
the government's intention is to still
make most most people pay for these
pumps can can you please confirm that
so
the the intent behind that is is we are
still looking at potentially making a
change uh but that said we're not going
to leave anyone behind just make sure
that can be affordable um but you know
this is the first step of consultation
the to get let people understand
what our initial thinking was but now we
need to go to the next step which is get
more feedback in terms of how it's going
to impact individuals
and then once we get that then we'll be
able to make a decision on how we're
going to
to move forward but the comment is that
in regardless of what we do whether we
change the program or not use a program
that's still on the table um it's
important that you know we we know we
need to support uh this community in
terms of ensuring that they have access
to uh
to pumps and that was always the intent
of providing a uh providing
better access to not only
the ones that are currently being
provided but you know
the new technology that's coming down
the uh coming down the height
but also to ensure that you know it's
affordable to uh to individuals on you
know that take advantage of this program
thanks minister michelle follow-up
yeah
minister you just talked about having
access to pumps but i mean having access
to pumps is one thing
having the government pay for those
pumps is quite another and it sounds to
me like
it's still a possibility that you're
gonna you guys are gonna go right ahead
with with the pro with the chain ending
program as previously announced
yeah so the whole purpose of doing the
consultation and as i indicated to your
colleague uh we should do this
consultation before we actually announce
the change so we're doing it right now
and the whole purpose of the
consultation to ensure that everyone can
get access to a pump and people aren't
going to have to make choices between
you know paying for groceries and and
and be able to get access to the pump
and it's not just about the pump it's
it's also about this is part of an
overall approach to improve access to
support people with diabetes
you know this is phase three you know
phase one and two
included you know better access to
testing strips for example and it also
included for you know
uh juvenile continuous glucose
monitoring so and there's more
technology that's coming down the pipe
so we you know we're looking at how do
we ensure that people be able to keep up
their pumps how do we ensure that
continues to be affordable which is the
purpose of the program
and then and be able to manage now and
into the future
thanks minister uh we'll wrap it there
thanks to everyone who called in uh
minister and dr hinshaw and as the
minister noted in case you missed it
we'll see you back here two weeks from
now and we'll let you know the exact
date as soon as we can thanks very much
thank you